in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadeon, for May 29th, on which we commemorate, our Holy Father
Luke, Archbishop of Simeferepol and the Crimea, the Blessed Surgeon, called in the world Valentine
Peliković, Wojno-Jasjeniecki. St. Luke was born in 1877, in Kerr, in the Ukraine, into a
noble Polish family. He was, from childhood, deeply interested in painting, and decided
to enter the Academy of Fine Arts in St. Petersburg. During the entrance examination, however, he was
seized by doubt, and decided that he had no right to do as he pleased, but must rather work to
alleviate the suffering of others. After a brief stay in Munich, he returned to Russia and began
to paint, but the Lord's words about the laborers in the vineyard called him to serve the people of
God. He decided on medicine and entered the key of faculty of medicine, and his talent for drawing
drew him towards a very precise study of anatomy. Having brilliantly completed his studies in 1903,
just before the outbreak of the Russo-Japanese War, he began his career as a field doctor in the hospital
of Kita, near Lake Baikal. There, he married a nurse, and they had four children. Transfer to the
hospital in Ardatov near Simbersk, and then to Lyuba near Kursk. He studied the problems produced by
the use of general anesthesia, and concluded that it should generally be replaced by local anesthesia.
Despite the precarious conditions, he frequently carried out successful operations, and this brought him
patients from the surrounding area. Having spent some time in Romanovka near Satarov, he became
doctor in charge of a 50-bed hospital in Petyaslavl-Saleski, where he developed an intensive surgical practice
in Moscow, while still continuing his research. In 1916, in Moscow, he successfully defended his
thesis on the use of local anesthesia, and began a study of separating wounds. In 1917, while the
revolution was roaring through the great cities, he was given medical charge of the large hospital in
Tashkent, where he went to live with his family, but his wife died soon after of tuberculosis. Being in
morning, he asked his nurse in the operating block to look after the children's education. She
agreed, and Dr. Valentine was able to go on working, both in the hospital and the university, where he
taught anatomy and surgery. He often took part in discussions on spiritual questions, where he spoke
against atheist materialism. After one of these meetings, at which he had spoken long and ardently,
Bishop Innocent told him, Dr. You must become a priest. Although he had never dreamed of ordination,
he accepted the bishops' suggestion. He was ordained deacon the following Sunday, and priest a
week later. He combined his tasks as Dr. Teacher and Priest, celebrating in the cathedral on Sundays and
giving lessons in his casak. He rarely celebrated the offices and the sacraments, but devoted himself to
ardent preaching, which he ended with discussions on contemporary spiritual subjects. For two years, he
held public debates with an apostate priest, who was responsible for anti-religious propaganda in the
area, and who died a shameful death. In 1923, when the Living Church Schism was sowing division and
confusion within the church, the bishop of Tashkent was forced to flee, leaving the diocese to the
care of Father Valentine and another archpriest. A bishop in exile, passing through the town,
approved the saint's election to the Episcopate, which had been determined by a council of the
clergy faithful to the church. After having concerted him in his room with the name of Luke, his bishop
sent him to a small town not far from Samarkand, where two bishops were living in exile so that his
consecration might take place in the greatest secrecy on the 18th of March in 1923. About 10 days after
his return to Tashkent and his first celebration of the Divine Liturgy, he was arrested by the secret
police, the GPU, and being accused of the counter-revolutionary activity and spying for England, was sentenced to two
years exile in Siberia, in the Tutankhansk region. Traveling in terrible conditions he was able to save
some of the sick whom he encountered on his journey from certain death. In exile, he worked in the hospital
where he performed important operations. As he blessed the sick and prayed before operating, the GPU
forbade him to do this and reacted strongly to the bishop's firm refusal to stop.
Some into the police station, he was given half an hour to pack his belongings and was sent by
sledge to the shore of the Arctic Ocean, where he spent the winter in various hamlets. At the beginning of
the Great Fast, he was recalled to Tutankh to resume his hospital work, the peasants having revolted
against his absence, which had left the hospital without a surgeon. Freed in 1926, he returned to
Tashkent and the following autumn, Metropolitan Sergei appointed him successively to reels,
Kursk diocese, then to Alets as assistant bishop and ultimately to Ezebsk as diocesan bishop.
On the advice of Metropolitan Arsenii of Novgorod, however, Bishop Luke refused and requested
retirement, a decision that he later bitterly regretted. He was left in peace to pursue his activities
for about three years. In early 1930, one of his colleagues in the Faculty of Medicine, Professor Mikhailovsky,
having lost heart after his son's death, attempted to revive the corpse with blood transfusions,
and then committed suicide. In response to the widow's requests, taking into account the deceased's
mental state, Bishop Luke authorized his church burial. The communist authorities made this a pretext
to accuse him of complicity in the professor's murder, and from religious fanaticism of
desiring to prevent the resurrection from the dead by means of materialist science.
He was arrested shortly before the destruction of the Church of St. Serges, in which he used to
preach, and underwent a series of interrogations after which he was put in a suffocating prison cell,
which damaged his precarious health. When he began a hunger strike in protest at this inhuman
treatment, a senior officer in the GPU promised to release him if he gave it up.
This officer broke his word, and the Holy Bishop was condemned to a further three-year exile in
Siberia, traveling in horrendous conditions. He lived in Kotla and Arkangelsk between 1931 and
1933, working in hospitals. Having developed a tumor, he went to Leningrad for surgery, and there,
one day when he was standing in church during the office, he had an overwhelming spiritual experience,
which reminded him of his intention to involve himself in the service of the Church.
Being taken to Moscow for further interrogation, he was offered circumstances favorable to his
continuing his scientific research, as long as he would renounce his priesthood. This he firmly
refused to do. Freed in 1933, he sought in order to continue his research to take charge of a vacant
diocese, but his request was finally refused, and he returned to Tashkent, where he was able to work
in a small hospital. In 1934, his essay on surgery and suburating wounds was published.
This was quickly to become a classic of medical science, and earned for him the Stalin prize and
international recognition. In the course of his work in Tashkent, he contracted a tropical disease
that caused a detached retina, but he continued his medical work until 1937. The terrible
persecutions then unleashed by Stalin, not only against believers and those opposed to the law,
but also against the communist leaders of the first years, poured millions of people into the
concentration camps. St. Luke was arrested, along with the Archbishop of Tashkent,
and all the clergy who had remained faithful to the church, accused of forming a clerical
counter-revolutionary organization. He was interrogated for 13 days and nights in succession,
under the blinding light of a projector. Police officers in relays questioned him
without a break, forcing him to contradict himself. When he began another hunger strike,
they sent the exhausted saint to the cellars of the secret police.
After further interrogation and torture, after which being at the end of his strength and having
no control over what he was doing, he signed, with a trembling hand, a confession of involvement
in an anti-communist plot. He was exiled to Siberia for the third time at the beginning of 1940
to the Krasnoyarsk region, at the cost of a thousand difficulties and setbacks.
He managed to continue his work as a surgeon and even to continue his research in Thomsk.
At the time of the invasion by Hitler's armies and the outbreak of a war that was to produce
millions of victims in 1941, he was appointed doctor in charge of the hospital in Krasnoyarsk,
with responsibility for the military hospitals in the entire region, while serving as diocesan
bishop of that area, in which the communists were boasting of having left not a single working church.
His services earned him a decoration for patriotism and metropolitan surges elevated him to the rank of
archbishop. It was in this capacity that he took part in the council of 1943, which elected
metropolitan surges as patriarch, and he was made a member of the permanent patriarchal synod.
As the war brought some relaxation of religious persecution, he established a vast program of
religious renewal and devoted himself to preaching with redoubled zeal. The hospital, being transferred
from Krasnoyarsk to Thombov in 1944, he settled there and took over the direction of the diocese,
while working on the publication of various medical and religious writings. In particular,
Anapologia against atheist materialism, entitled On Spirit, Soul and Body. In this, he upheld the
principles of Christian anthropology by the application of solid scientific argument. In 1946,
he was moved to the Crimea and made archbishop of Sinfetopoul. He had there, first of all, to work on
the reform of clerical behavior. He taught that a priest's heart must be a fire that burned with a light
of the gospel and his love for the cross, both in word and deed. Heart disease forced him to stop
operating, but he continued to give free consultations and to advise other doctors in the region.
During this period, several miraculous healings were wrought through his prayers. He became
completely blind in 1956, but this did not prevent his celebrating the divine liturgy by heart.
Preaching and administering his diocese, he courageously opposed the closing of churches
and the various forms of persecution, which the authorities cunningly unleashed.
Full of days and having accomplished his work of witnessing to the Lord crucified for our salvation,
he fell asleep in peace on the 11th of June, May 29, 1961.
All the clergy of the diocese and a great crowd of the faithful were present at his funeral,
and his grave quickly became a place of pilgrimage, many healings taking place there to this day.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.